hello and welcome back to game review my
name is Caleb Denby and today I will be
taking you through a game from the tata
steel's masters tournament but however
this one is not from this year in fact
it is from 2013 and this is a game
played by the former world champion of
SWANA thunder nonce against Levon
Aronian another world class player and
this is a pretty famous game in fact
it's been called an ons a mortal game
and I think the reason for that will
become pretty evident once we start
going through some of these moves so the
game was played after d4 d5 we see c4 c6
a Slav Knight f3 Knight f6 Knight c3 and
after ISA 'kx we arrive at the semi Slav
III is White's choice in this game
Knight bd7
Bishop d3 now that white has committed
to developing this bishop we can take on
c4 kind of force him to based a tempo
recapturing this pawn black expands very
quickly on the Queen side with b5 Bishop
d3 and now Bishop d6 castles castles and
this is pretty well known theory Queen
c2 Bishop b7 is another point to this b5
move clearing this space for the Bishop
a3 white looking to stop any b4 advances
and now Rick c8 for black and here white
plays a move
Knight g5 and this is a pretty
interesting move here I think it was a
pretty new move at the time of game
that's been tried a few more times since
then and the point of 9 g5 is pretty
obvious we're attacking this H pawn and
now there's a couple ways that that
black can deal with this it might be
natural to play a move like h6 simply
stepping this pawn out of the way but
now this night will come to e4 and
things like Knight takes e4 Knight takes
e4 aren't really what what black is
looking for here this bishops going to
be a little bit awkward you're going to
have to move it back to e7 likely you're
likely going to have to move it back to
e7
not really what you want so instead of
h6 black here came up with what might be
a better move in c5 and this is a very
very ambitious move it allows white to
capture aged seven either way both are
playable moves for for white it also
leaves this beep on behind all for the
sake of breaking in the center as fast
as possible and so here
LaVon had to make a decision there's
really only two real moves here
that's Bishop h7 Ornette h7 in the game
LaVon pick tonight h7 just briefly we'll
look at Bishop h7 the king will come to
h8 and after f/4g 6 is blacks point
trying to trap this Bishop Bishop takes
G 6 F takes you six is a piece sacrifice
and you can imagine a knight takes B 5
Bishop b8 something like Queen takes g6
and historically this has turned out to
be totally fine for for black the couple
times it's been tried in in practical
play here and so well this is another
interesting line Livan in the game shows
Knight age 7 and now black plays a very
very interesting move he doesn't worry
about this rook on f8 which isn't really
going to be contributing to this attack
that he's launching by opening up to
these bishops so he leaves the rook in
take and plays rook or Knight g4 instead
obviously hitting this h2 pawn it's a
sore spot for white so white plays f4
trying to prevent black from using these
bishops effectively black plays a very
natural move C takes d4 he takes d4
opening up the rook in full view of the
Queen and then this is where our Anand
really starts playing some some crazy
chests here you need some way to
continue this attack you've given up
this pawn on h7 you've kind of invited
the white pieces into your home into
your Kings side here and so you need to
play very very actively and so if you
want to at home try and find the only
move for black to play for an advantage
here you can pause the video here
I will be very very surprised and very
impressed if anybody actually does
manage to find this move who hasn't seen
the game before that move is Bishop c5
and this move is crazy obviously you're
just putting your bishop on a square
where it can be captured the point is if
it isn't captured this Bishop is going
to be eyeing this d4 pawn and indirectly
this King but okay what happens if we
capture it well after a long and
complicated tactical line where both
players are taking a ton of pieces we
can imagine night c5 hits this bishop
and also creates a threat of queen d4
let's say white captures this rook we
could give this check and after King h1
we could take this bishop and now we're
looking to play Knight f2 h3 is White's
best move Knight DF to check forces
white to sacrifice this exchange where
it takes F 2 and after Knight takes up 2
you check King H 2 this is the point of
h3 and King takes f8 we can see at the
end of the day material has actually
been balanced but black has a huge lead
in activity and development here with
this bishop on c1 and rook on a1 both
sitting out of the game that being said
maybe this line was was the best that
white could actually hope for going back
though Aronian made the judgment call
that he could not capture this Bishop on
c5 because that position does look
rather uncomfortable for white and said
he chose this move Bishop e2 which would
be a pretty good move if not for Anand
next move so once again at home if you
want to try to find the best move here
for black I will award you three gold
stars if you manage to find this move
it's it's a it's a very very very nice
one so I encourage you to try but I wish
you the best of luck ok
the answer is Knight d5 this is the move
for black that seals the deal so in the
past two moves we saw an on to play
Bishop c5 or the bishop can be taken and
now 95 where the knight can be taken
taken in two different manners so what's
the point this time well the easy one is
what happens if you take this night
either way queen takes d4 check King
each one and then we've all seen this
one before
Knight f2 checkmate but what happens if
you take the bishop well the answer is
still Queen d4 check and if King h1 will
play Knight f2 check
forcing rook takes f2 if King g1
obviously it's the same story so rook F
2 and now after Queen f2 we're simply
giving checkmate on the G 2 square by
force no way to stop it so with that in
mind
Anand puts both of those pieces right in
front of the white pawns but neither can
be captured so Aronian plays the best
move Bishop takes g4 trying to trade off
one of these nights at least but now
Anand can solve his problems play the
move Bishop takes d4 check removing this
bishop from capture and after king h1
Knight takes G for we are making a lot
of the same threats with Knight F 2 as
before hands and none of our pieces can
be captured besides of course this rook
which white does in fact choose to take
and now because Anand is one of the best
chess players of all time
he didn't capture this knife back I
think I would I think most people would
instead though he plays this move f5 and
the point to f5 is that after King f8
Anand probably didn't want to let this
Queen get into h7 thought I was you know
just causing too many problems it
prevents my Queen from coming out to h4
why would I allow that who needs this
night anyways simply f5 blocking this
Queen from entering the game Aronian
shows Knight g6 trying to keep an eye on
this h4 square but after Queen f6 this
night is going to die we see h3 Aronian
tries to take this thing in return for
this night but no such luck after Queen
g6 you cannot capture here due to
checkmate
so instead we see Queenie - and now
after Queen age five we see Queen D
three and I'll let you try to find the
final move of this game that forced
resignation from Levon Aronian okay
final move the game can you do it
hopefully you could the move is Bishop
III of course the point being if you
capture this Bishop Queen takes h3 takes
advantage of a pin and Queen h2 or g2
are both checkmate
so the Bishop e3 no good way to deal
with this Queen takes h3 threat so Levon
Aronian resigned once again a very
impressive game from Viswanath on Anand
perhaps his best of all time it's been
called an ons a mortal game and it's a
very very fun one to see all of these
plays pieces being placed where they
could be captured and all of these
threats against the White King
culminating in a very nice move Bishop
e3 threatening and unstoppable checkmate
thank you very much for joining me in
today's game review my name is Caleb
Denby and I will see you in the next
episode